Get ready. It's going to make you cry.
It's going to anger you, but it's going
to show you the beauty of Jesus.
The beauty of Jesus. We're going to
start at the 23-minute mark.
23-minute mark.
Okay. The beauty of Jesus. 23-minute
mark.
Watch the beauty of Jesus, the joy of
Jesus in this Palestinian Christian.
Right? Watch as he recounts the horrors
by settlers who came and took his land.
Cuz there were also Palestinian
Christians who owned land.
It wasn't just the Muslims.
So, let's go here.
Let's play this clip. I have to play
this clip.
Let me see what the timestamp.
Remember,
YouTube copyright law allows for fair
use of excerpts.
So, for the sake of this
uh for the sake of this analogy, imagine
they come and they build fence around
this property. And now it cuts your
property in a half and sometimes it
slice it up. So, you become San Diego
becomes fragmented.
And they set up this fence around it.
They take the water resources. He's
giving an analogy. What if Mexico came
to San Diego and did what Israel did to
the Palestinians? Do you understand the
analogy? Listen to the analogy.
They built walls, sniper towers, and all
of the sudden you see the Mexican army
coming to protect those new settlers.
And those settlers are not friendly
neighbors. They're not coming to San
Diego to be neighbors.
They're coming to take the land from San
Diego.
And now if you are a mother, a Christian
mother who puts
>> Watch here.
Listen to the story. her children in
Christian school.
And you want and and your school now
is behind those
new roads that these Mexican settlers
built.
They built a new road that connects San
Diego to Tijuana. Listen to this. Across
the border.
And you are a mother who wants to go who
wants to drop off her kids
to a school that is beyond
those bypass road only. Yep, listen to
this.
And this is not theoretical for us. This
is not theoretical. This example I gave
you is not theoretical. Listen. Please
listen. I'm going to have to stop at a
key point so I don't get flagged. And I
know I don't think Tucker Carlson will
flag me cuz he allows for excerpts. But
listen.
This is reality. When you go to Bet
Sahour, you will see the settlements
encircling the little town, choking it.
It's like slow suffocation. It prevents
it from its natural growth.
That story that I told you about the
mother is actually my cousin. My cousin.
Who takes her
uh children
She has twins and she has a 6-year-old.
>> Listen to this. To American Evangelical
school built in Bet Sahour.
And with this new settlement they have
built, they have set up a roadblock, a
checkpoint where Israeli come and man
those checkpoint to protect the
settlers.
Now one day she was taking her children
to school.
Protect the settlers, not the
Palestinians. To protect the settlers.
So his cousin, right? Watch.
Taking them to an American Evangelical
school.
Listen.
And the Israeli army pointed guns at
them
>> Oh, come on.
>> instructing them
to let the kids walk
across the checkpoint to make it to the
school to the other side. Now, this is
not an incin- isolated incident. This is
not something that happens every once in
a while.
The army is always present to protect
the settlers.
So, my cousin told her 6-year-old,
Listen to this. "You're strong. You can
do this.
And you can we can walk through it. The
teacher on the other side is going to
receive you."
As soon as she walked, she held her head
head up high. She passed through the
soldier. Listen to this. And she fainted
at the feet of the school staff.
Do you see what happened to the mother?
They didn't allow her to drive to the
school. She had to take her 6-year-old
walk 5 ft.
By the time she get to the school, she
fainted from the exhaustion.
Yeah, but they're liars, you know? I
mean remember remember it's a Zionism.
It's it's all lie propaganda. The
Palestinian nun, she's a sister of
George Soros. She can't trust her. The
Lutheran Palestinian pastor, you can't
trust him because he's Palestinian.
Oh, but well, yeah, Lutheran but I don't
You would think people now see what this
evil satanic system is.
If Epstein has not convinced you
this Zionist ideology is from the pit of
hell, they are of the devil,
synagogue of Satan trying to now control
the world,
I don't know what to tell you.
Stephanopoulos, I'm sorry. It wasn't you
but isn't it George Soros?
Isn't George Stephanopoulos also George
Soros? Well, anyway, one of them.
Because I guess she's uh related to some
liberal. I don't know.
I don't follow the politicians, right?
But you see
And now, by the way, we're going to war
with Iran. Do you know that, right?
You know that, right?
You were going to war with Iran, right?
It's already announced.
I I believe this weekend they're going
to attack Iran because they're going to
start a war.
You know that, right?
But nonetheless, it is what it is.
United States of Zion.
United States of Epstein. Okay, now
let's continue.
Now, this is brings a lot of
psychological trauma.
Watch this. This is how [music]
pickpockets in the United States are
stealing wallets right now. 2 sec Uh
it brings a lot of nightmares. That's
what Christian families in Beit Sahour
are experiencing.
Now, I remember I told you about this.
Uh our our our home back in Beit Sahour,
it's not too far from the school. It's
not too far from the new settlement they
are building in Beit Sahour. Now, watch
what happened to his mother. Guys, an
eyewitness this happened to him. But
come on, man.
These Palestinian bro, they're lying.
Remember, in Israel, the Christian
community has increased by 84%. What's
wrong with you?
Won't you ever be happy?
The Christian community has increased by
84% in Israel. What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you?
Listen here.
And down the road is the Israeli bypass
road, which is only for settlers and and
Israeli armed vehicles.
In 1990
Watch. we watch settlers come and go.
There was an Israeli army vehicle that
stopped. Listen. And we saw I was 10 at
the time.
I saw an Israeli soldier stepping out of
the vehicle, pointing a rifle at us, and
he start shooting at us. Are you
We were a bunch of kids. I mean, my my
my siblings, my mother was there, and
some of my cousins. He start shooting
live ammunition at us. And then my
mother rushed us all into the door.
She was the last one to get in. She
caught a bullet in the back.
>> Your mo- Jared?
He was 10 years old.
Her mom His mom caught a bullet in the
back.
Jared?
No, but he's a liar. Do what he's
Palestinian, bro. Remember
the Christian community has increased by
84% in Israel.
Remember
the Christian community has increased by
84%.
What's wrong with you?
Okay, watch here.
bunch of kids. I mean, my my my
siblings, my mother was there, and some
of my cousins. He starts shooting live
ammunition at us. And then my mother
rushed us all into the door.
She was the last one to get in. She
caught a bullet in the back. Your
mother? Yes, my own mother.
Who loves the Lord and she loves Jesus.
Mhm. And exit wound, she dropped Come
on. She dropped on the floor. Yeah, but
you don't love Netanyahu. You don't love
Zionism.
You don't love the Wailing Wall.
So what she loves Jesus?
You don't love Netanyahu. You don't love
Zionism. You don't love the Wailing
Wall.
That's what matters, dude.
That if you
call upon Netanyahu, you'll be saved.
Let me hear that part again.
And she caught a bullet in the back.
Your mother? Yes, my own mother.
Who loves the Lord and she loves Jesus.
Doesn't matter. And exit wound, she
dropped Come on. She dropped on the
floor. Pool of blood. I heard I heard to
the to the back door, called my dad, my
uncle who was a physician, put pressure
on the wound, took her to the hospital.
Watch here. Saved her You saw this
happen? This in front of In front of my
eyes. In front of my My own mother. I'm
sorry. I should say we've been talking
off camera before we started this
interview, and I detect I I didn't know
the story.
It's not my interview notes and I
detected no bitterness whatsoever in
anything that you said. I don't know how
>> Okay. No bitterness. Now watch the
spirit of Jesus Christ shine through
him.
No bitterness. Listen. Listen. Listen.
Sorry, so you're just shocking me. I
didn't expect to hear that. Palestinian
Christians
take the Sermon of the Mount very
seriously, apparently.
When Jesus comes and he elevates our
thinking.
When he elevates our
outlook on life. Amen.
>> When he takes morality
to a whole new standard. When he said,
"You have heard do not kill. But I tell
you, if you look at your brother and you
call him raqa, Aramaic word for fool or
stupid
>> Right. Preaching. you just have
committed a murder. Exactly. And when he
said, and remember the context, Jesus
was talking to
a Jewish audience who were under
ruthless Roman occupation. Yes. They
were persecuted. They were
uh discriminated against. It was very
brutal to live under the Roman
occupation. But Jesus telling his
followers, "Love your enemies." See?
"Pray for those who persecute you."
>> Okay.
This is something that we have grow up
We have grown up understanding the very
essence
and the meaning
of the Sermon of the Mount. You heard?
We live the Sermon of the Mount.
We have no choice but to live the Sermon
of the Mount.
Because we, like the Jews of the first
century, are under occupation and being
persecuted. And you know what's ironic?
The Jews are the new Romans.
The Romans did to the Jews what the Jews
are now doing to
the Palestinians, specifically the
Christians. The Christians.
See that? And now watch the impact he
makes on Tucker. Watch here. Watch the
impact he makes on Tucker.
Look at Tucker's reaction. He's shocked.
Wow. I'm sorry. I I've totally derailed
your story because I'm just shocked. I
really didn't know that was coming. So,
you you're 10 years old. You watch your
mother get shot by this Okay, so many
questions.
Why did he do this? Who has a better
life, cats or dogs?
>> Sadly, cats are often seen as low
maintenance. So, owners don't give them
the mental stimulation You know,
this has been just
random.
They do this not just to Palestinian
Christians. I mean, that has been the
policy. It's They do it to the Muslims.
They do it to any Palestinians. See? Did
she survive? She did. Miraculously, it
was The bullet was
just millimeters away from the spine.
Jared,
millimeters away from the spine.
Pray for me, Daniel, that Jesus protect
me and I stay holy
and protect me from the backlash cuz the
cult leader is going to manifest.
Ginja, report to your boss. Ginja.
See that?
It was an American rifle, I assume.
Who knows? Of course. We don't know the
soldier.
>> 5.56 round, right? Yeah. Okay, so that's
my next question. So,
so some soldier, your mother wasn't
throwing rocks at him or screaming for
jihad or anything.
>> playing in front of the house.
You see that, Pajoga? You're right,
guys. Rumble, I'm watching your
comments, too.
So, she wasn't calling jihad. No, but
it's Hamas. Hamas. They love Hamas. See,
the Christians are supporting Hamas.
They're evil. See?
The work, right?
They were just kids playing.
How can you How can you How can you live
in this country and listen to people who
have no idea what they're talking about?
>> is This is the real threat of the the
settlements, okay? It's not just
taking Christian land.
It's not
acquiring and taking by force the
resources of the land.
Buddy, it's not Christian land, dude. My
will tell you Israel's the chosen
people. It's their land. You stole it,
you dirty kaffir.
You idolater, you know, Orthodox Jews,
don't forget this, will not enter a
church cuz
they consider us to be idolaters.
They'll enter a mosque and worship.
Keep that in mind.
Now watch what one
Israeli soldier told a Christian woman.
of Christian land who lived there for
generations.
It's inviting
violent settlers
to your neighborhood.
They're coming to take the land. They're
coming to squeeze. They're coming to
crush. They're coming to do that.
>> What did you do? Watch here. Listen.
being born in the I don't understand the
hate and I I certainly have been the
target of it, but I do I don't
understand I mean, I understand why
people don't like me. I'm doing
interviews like this, but I don't
understand why
the
why would someone shoot a mother in
front of her children? Like I just don't
get that. Like what is that?
You interviewed Bishop Hussam
and he mentioned the story, the recent
story just last month. Yeah.
Bishop Hussam, right? I believe that's
that Lutheran pastor, Palestinian. See,
but these Palestinian Christians,
they're all part of the conspiracy.
Because remember, Christian communities
have increased by 84% in Israel. So,
these guys are all haters.
They don't want to admit they stole the
land from Israel. It's Israel's land.
They love Hamas.
They're just using Christianity.
Yes. The attack on a Christian widow.
She's a Christian widow.
That And violent settler came to her
property grazing on the on on the in the
land with his cattle and then he hits
her with a stone on her head. Jared?
A Christian widow, defenseless widow, uh
Israeli settler comes, bashes her with a
rock in her house, in her house.
In her house.
Fractures her skull, takes her to you
know,
it's a she almost lost her life and when
her son tried to defend her, the son
gets arrested by the Israeli military.
And then when the settlers, bunch of
settlers, they showed up at the house in
the presence and the full support and
the complicity of the Israeli army, they
knocked down the door.
Her daughter was inside, Maryam, and I
talked to her.
I talked to her. The widow head bashed,
son
arrested.
She's in the house. I talked to her.
Look, look, she does the sign of the
cross, listen. She drew the sign of the
cross.
And when they found out that she was
Christian, you know what that settler
told her? What? He told her, "What are
you doing here? This is not your land.
You don't belong here." He said, "Go to
France or go somewhere else. You don't
belong here. God gave us this land."
Isn't that what Christian Zionists says?
"God gave us this land." So wait.
Guys, again, I don't think he got the
memo.
Don't you know that Christian
communities have increased by 84% in
Israel?
You see what he said to the young lady?
"What are you doing here? You don't
belong here. Go to some place like
France. God gave us this land."
Everyone got it or no?
You see why they're going to now
manifest and they're going to hate this
interview?